pas on va rappeler votre vie bajra parce
que mine de rien il ya plein de gens et
plein de jeunes gens qui savent pas
vraiment qui vous êtes
benjamin castadi oui ce n'est pas
seulement ce présentateur du nord vous
avez une famille extrêmement c'est
l'époux savoir votre grand père s'était
il monte ans est un des plus grands
acteurs
voilà et chanteurs ont vraiment pour
qu'on ait connu en france est un des
mecs les plus célèbres mais voilà il est
du music hall et même de tous voilà
c'est vrai et votre grand mère c'est
simone signoret immense actrice votre
père jean-pierre comédien jean-pierre
castaldi votre maman on y voit la
comédienne voilà et c'est vrai que vous
déjà je sais que vous écrivez un livre
sur votre famille ouais vous allez
révéler des secrets de famille n'ont pas
de secrets a pas que je vais révéler moi
même mes canons c'est vrai que moi j'ai
dû me suis marié beaucoup de fois et
c'est vrai que moi vous êtes mariée deux
fois pour les belges vont se marier
quatre fois à chaque fois hélas assez
souvent et c'est vrai que dans l'hérault
dès que j'ai dans ma vie c'est vrai que
j'ai une touche de trois enfants 3 3
garçons alors on va on va on va rappeler
trois enfants d'abord et c'est 3 février
julien dont c'est l'anniversaire ce soir
d'ailleurs le grand la wii simon
benneteau alors c'est tous de la même la
même femme c'est pas la même portée non
alors alors dites-nous bas alors julien
julien et simon cc avec valérie et lors
de votre première femme oui mais c'est
avec flavie donc oui d'accord
donc c'est vrai que bon et enzo je me
suis plutôt beaucoup occupé même si on a
divorcé assez tôt avec la vie je viens
quand je suis partie de mes trois ans
mais sinon il y avait neuf mois ses taux
et ça donc
voilà donc vous voulez ce soir si ces
comptes sur les véhicules
non mais c'est vrai parce que je rate un
beaucoup de choses maintenant avec l'uja
ce qu'il est à la maison parce que ce
fort ensemble on se parle et c'est super
je te reverrai en fait payer pas l'air
comme ça mais je raisonne voilà pardon
pardon à julien avant six mois
je vous aime tous
ces quatorze soit vouliez dire pardon à
vos enfants puisque vous vous trouvez
vous n'y étiez pas s'est présentée j'ai
pas été là on passe mon gars c'est notre
carrière c'est quoi c'est la carrière
c'est quand on est amoureux vous est ce
que c'est on est une femme on vise on en
convient ses astuces et histoire d'amour
il ya forcément des victimes les
victimes malheureusement c'est souvent
les enfants parce qu'on est on pense à
soi parce qu'on dit qu'on est égoïste
voilà on vit une histoire d'amour on a
envie de la vivre pleinement voilà et on
n'est pas là moi je suis parti trois ans
en amérique donc très peu eu lui la
veille il avait neuf mois j'avais une
sorte d'amour avec la vie donc je vois
là où c'est évident qu'ils ont senti que
j'étais pas présent mais attends ça va
mieux je suis content vraiment je suis
très heureux il vit avec moi le si beau
jeu aujourd'hui vous avez l'impression
ce que c'est je connais bien j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui vous en
donner même encore plus voilà je suis
maintenant mais j'ai la chance d'être
dans les deux homos sous mon toit takita
jebba ggn zoé simon avec les défis
d'ordre
enfin j'ai une grande famille qui
vraiment recomposée et c'est très
agréable parce qu'il était bon je fais
des choses que j'ai jamais fait dans ma
vie parce que effectivement quand on est
animateur on avait connu le succès à ces
jeunes à 30 ans avec le l'offre où on se
brûle les ailes et on passe à côté d'eux
un moment avec quand vous étiez dans le
loft quand vous étiez dans un succès
incroyable
vous avez un mot vous êtes dit je passe
à côté je vois mes enfants ce qu'il faut
c'est que c'est pas quand on le vit
c'est après parce qu'effectivement il ya
des rancoeurs et julien et sinon ils ont
été en colère on le sent un enfant et
puis parce que c'est compliqué au début
parce qu'ils ont plein de reproches et
qui savent pas quand il exprimé parce
qu'un enfant il va vous dire des choses
dans le mauvais ordre toujours sur un
mot sur un détail à vous jeter à la
gueule des tas de choses qui font très
mal
donc moi aujourd'hui je suis très
heureux parce que je raterais beaucoup
de choses avec avec mes trois enfants
avec simon parce que c'est lui me gêne
je pense le moins vu et c'est vrai que
ce matin j'étais au sport avec lui c'est
génial oui là il a 19 ans
on fait plein de trucs ensemble
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire de
julien julien hillat il ya quinze jours
il a 23 ans 3 23h23 dans l ain julien il
est là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien qu'en mai 2009
je t'aime mon chéri qu'est-ce qu'est ce
t'as envie de dire à ton papa ce soir
qui est un mec que j'adore tu le sais
regardez comme il est sensible suis là
déjà il voit pas ses yeux quand il
pleure pas leurs noms mais sans rigoler
quand il pleure alors là on y pullulent
à un projet bien question voulais lui
dire il a fait ce qu'il a plu et ça
change tu vois c'est ça reste ton père
tu fais il a fait il l'a fait des choix
il a fait il l'a fait pour lui il les a
faits pour nous aussi parce que j'aimais
lui manquer de rien juste que voilà il
le temps tu le rattrape pas mais tu tues
il n'y a pas d'âge pour changer et il
l'a fait aujourd'hui regard dit là il a
sinon chez lui moi j'ai commencé un
petit peu ma vie tu vois j'ai quitté le
nid est l'équité le n'y a pas longtemps
j'ai pris mon appartement la ja il ya un
an qu'une caution
[Rires]
je lui en veux de rien il a été il a
quand même été là tant qu'il a pu
et voilà j'ai eu c'est que je laime tu
as envie de profiter de ton papa
aujourd'hui
ouais j'aimerais beaucoup je peux tu
adressé à lui dira-t-il à testour à lui
dire aujourd'hui je suis fier de toi il
le sait je suis je suis fier d'avoir le
père que j'ai et voilà il n'y a pas
d'âge pour
pour changer les choses et franchement
c'est l'heure actuelle voilà c'est un
père au top sur un père au top et où il
voulait vous dire pardon ce soir benji
c'est premier truc qui nous a dit quand
on a dit c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui sa
journée internationale du pardon et il a
dit je veux dire pardon mes enfants
est-ce que tu comprends voilà qui qui
qui veuille vous dire pardon où tu dis
moi pour moi il a été toujours présent
il
voilà je n'ai pas ressenti comme lui a
pu le ressentir ce n'est pas d'hier
était présente à vos yeux
il n'a pas été il n'a pas été très
présent mais mais pardon c'est trop
facile c'est tu peux pas on peut pas
dire pardon cesser les regrets mais j'ai
pas lui pardonner de ça et c'est il a eu
la vie il a vécu sa vie j'ai manqué de
rien peut-être d'en perdre un peu plus
présent mais voilà alors veut pas du
tout je lui en veux pas parce que parce
que parce que c'est je pense que quand
on est face à
au choix qu'il a dû faire face quand on
a la vie qu'il a eu forcément à un
moment où voilà il tu dois faire des
choix et il les a faits ça ne fait pas
de moi quelqu'un de malheureux loin de
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un abandon jute un amour je te fais un
gros bisou bon anniversaire
personne c'est un gros cadeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je t'offre un cadeau time of which et al
hilal que tu as envie de payer des
voyages en grèce en ce moment les
voyages en relation un voyage en grèce
bah ouais si je te mets je te fais
partir en guerre
abordable